the Marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die discipline means taking the hard
road the uphill road to do what's right
for yourself and for other people and
sometimes a big part of success is just
not being lazy and just doing it yeah
just get that's like 90% of its just
showing up
what's that believe nation its heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world now I started to
believe life series to try to tackle
different topics outside of just
hardcore business instead of help you
live your best believe life today we're
gonna look at the one thing that only 1%
of people do enjoy
[Music]
dude screamed to me the other night a
will I wanna be active man I will be
active just like you
you know usually people say stuff to me
like that I'm like a man you know you do
is give them an encouraging word but I
was just sitting here thinking and it
dawned on me 99% of people that say
stuff like that are not willing to do
what it takes to make their dreams come
true the Marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die and that's just real at the
center of bringing any dream into
fruition is self discipline you know
something something as simple as food
and eating it is not about your body as
much as it is about your mind it's
getting command of your mind to be able
to choose actions that are in your own
best interest every day we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you in the
world's trying to hold you down so
you're gonna kick yourself in the balls
so you will stop yourself from getting
what you dream self-discipline is the
center of all material success you
cannot win the war against the world if
you can't win the war against your own
mind I always say that discipline is the
loop of all good qualities but you have
to absolutely apply it to things outside
of just waking up early it's it's
everything it's working now every day
making yourself stronger and faster and
more flexible and healthier discipline
is eating the right foods to fuel your
system it
it's about disciplining your emotions so
you can make good decisions it's about
having the discipline to control your
ego so your ego doesn't get out of hand
and control you it's about treating
people the way you would want to be
treated and doing the tasks that you
don't necessarily want to do but that
you know will help you or help your team
it's about facing your fears takes
discipline to face your fears so you can
conquer them and that's what discipline
is discipline means taking the hard road
the uphill road to do what's right for
yourself
and for other people it's so often the
easy path the easy path that calls to us
to be weak for that moment to break down
for that moment to give in to the desire
and the short-term gratification but the
discipline will not allow that the
discipline calls for strength and
fortitude and will it won't accept
weakness it won't tolerate another
breakdown the discipline in seem like
it's your worst enemy but the reality is
discipline is your best friend it will
take care of you like nothing else can
and it'll put you on that path the path
to strength and health and intelligence
and happiness and most importantly it'll
put you on that path to freedom
it sounds like yo you got to discipline
yourself I started looking at mother
Teresa of Gandhi and I was like yo bro
Gandhi would go fast from sex and he was
married he would fast from talking you
know I just started watching these great
peoples like all these people fast and
not about fast and like that's not the
peace but they were very disciplined
people and they would not allow their
exterior world to dominate or destroy
their internal world I just like you I
want to get to a place where I can
control me my family members have grown
a loss too uncle cirrhosis of the liver
brilliant man but just drinking drinking
drinking and I was like yo I do not want
to my father was a substance abuser for
years I was like yo I don't want a life
where something else is controlling me
you know like when I left home and said
I don't want to be controlled no more
like I meant that like I don't know
nothing to control me but me and so I
got to put myself under extreme
discipline to make sure I'm free so when
people see me you get up at 3:00 you
don't drink you don't smoke I'm not
doing that because I think I'm better
than a BYOs oh I think you gonna go to
hell because you had a drink I just want
I want to control I want freedom and for
me disciplining myself means more
freedom and unless I you discipline
yourself people who I told my son other
dads like your son I do not want you to
have fun I just seen a history of people
who just have fun Christmas Thanksgiving
Halloween know there are the people are
still nice Friday every night there are
the people who end up in a 20s having a
great deal of fun but in a 40s and 50s
they were working for somebody and I'm
not saying nothing wrong with cleaning
toilets but they doing something they
don't want to do for the rest of their
life and they can't retire because they
plays so much you know so for me I just
look at Venus in Sarina Michael Jackson
when he used to like five and sixes
dancing all night
I just think the more man discipline
himself the greater you don't mean it's
gonna happen but the greater the
probability that he has this sense of
freedom well I think the one thing that
discipline definitely does help you with
is it helps you get things done and when
you get things done when you actually do
things you you you do you have more
success if you have more success
sometimes a big part of success is just
not being lazy and just doing it yeah
just get that's like 90% of it is just
showing up get there and start working
like you're not gonna feel perfect every
day if I felt if I only worked out when
I felt good I'd be a theft because
there's a lot of days I don't want to do
it if it's pretty much the same with
everybody that if that actually gets
good at something that you you get
there's got to be those days you push
through and they're them they're
probably gonna be more numerous than the
days you don't and so the benefit of
discipline in my eyes has always been
that through discipline I get things
done I always tell my always say that
I'm like the most lazy disciplined
person I know because I don't want to do
it yeah
but I always do the thing about
self-discipline is that it is necessary
for everything you do in your life
you have to be self discipline if
discipline comes from somewhere else
it's very very hard to remain consistent
because you tend to resist it's wild
because I see trainers and they're in
the gym with people and you know the guy
or girl that they're working out hates
their workout hates it because the
discipline is coming from somewhere else
you it's something that you dread every
time you go in you don't really want to
do it it's like oh but oh no my trainers
here he's about to you know beat me up
and make me feel crazy well the truth is
every trainer should work his way out of
your life anybody who's working you out
your teachers your trainers your people
they have to train you to get out of
your life now so you can go ahead do
your
work out do your own thing practice
self-discipline now one thing I want to
straighten out big-time discipline is
not punishment it's not discipline it's
training that's all it is I was talking
to my son one time and I asked him it
was weird because I was trying to see if
he really knew what it was all about and
I said hey man you know I have to
discipline you
what is discipline he goes punishment
punishment when I do something wrong and
you punish me I was like no no
discipline is training if you change
your mind your mindset and really focus
it on what discipline really is you
start to welcome discipline you welcome
self discipline into your life
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Patrick Bay divided on how to
develop discipline but before that I
want to know what has been the biggest
struggle for you to be able to develop
your own self-discipline leaving the
comments below I want to check it out I
want to help and hopefully believe me
she can rally to help you too so put it
in the comments thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
my guaranteed formula for success that
is 100% proven for my life and other
people have taught out work out improve
outlast and out strategies again out
work out improve outlets out strategize
what you're looking on the screen here
on the screen look at those four again
what you're looking on on the screen
here which of those four things that
you're looking at the out work out
improve outlets out strategize which of
those four things do you think comes
last meaning you'll learn the latter the
latest it's out strategize why because
that requires a lot of experience it's
like you got to go through like a
general in the war right you got to go
through so many different words to learn
different strategies and what works and
what tactics works on what doesn't work
that's something you gotta be working on
right however the other three outwork if
a guy works 80 hours a week and you work
40 hours a week you can't compete with
that guy if some if you yourself are
reading two three four books a month and
you develop in your mind and your
competitor is not and he only reads one
or two and you study in industry
articles and all the subs and they're
not you know you're studying how to
recruit CEO CFO CEO CMOS what is the
best way to stretch this million dollar
investment that I got to make this
happen who should I talk to to be part
of a group for mentors and CEOs group
and all these who should I network with
what community should I be a part of
who's the best engineers IT firm to hire
what are these competitors doing what
are some of the guys that are not even
on my mark if you start studying those
industry somebody else isn't it's tough
to compete with you and then outlast
some people work 80 hours a week for a
year and that's great but they can't
work 80 hours a week for three years
some work 80 hours a week for three
years but you work 80 hours a week for
five years you outlasted the guy that
the three years are one year they can't
compete with you because the compounding
effort favors you so these four things
that you look at on the screen require
one thing and that's discipline and the
discipline part you don't hear a lot
about that's the things people doing
nobody else sees that's when you win if
you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it don't you
believe you act like I am Tulsa what a
whale out of handcuffed lightning both
London's
now you know I'm bad over the last week
I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between thirty seconds and five minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access